ah hello wordsmiths you found me in my
workshop coining new words a little
soldering a little welding and there you
are a brand new word let's take it out
of the forge and see what I've made oh
well this word already exists it's
Innovative
inovative it's an adjective it means
coming up with new ideas or approaches
inventive so an Innovative idea might
require a new approach to a problem new
is important here and I'll explain when
we get into the words
origins in means in or on no means new
from the Latin Novus and eight makes the
word into a verb right and so that's
innovate to make something new I if
makes that verb into an adjective
Innovative a way to describe something
as newly invented or newly introduced so
let's think about that nove word part
noov how many words can you think of
that have that in there I'll give you 10
seconds and a little music break to
think it over Okay meet back here in
[Music]
10 here's what I came up with novice a
noun it means newbie someone who's a
beginner novel which is a noun or an
adjective as a noun it's a fiction book
right it's something original and new
that hasn't happened before thus novel
that's what the adjective form means too
a novel concept is something wholly new
and Novelty which means kind of silly
new thing a novelty is Trivial frivolous
goofy novelty music is a whole entire
genre of very silly music that I love a
great deal if you look closely at the
grocery store you'll see that the
section where the ice cream sandwiches
are is usually labeled Frozen Novelties
Wordsmith I would be so good at
inventing Frozen Novelties okay Frozen
novelty innovator over here Cherry ice
cream between two Thin slabs of brownie
but the ice cream part is rolled in
chocolate shavings I could make a mint
as an ice cream innovator a chocolate
mint H all right let's use Innovative in
a sentence Nick's Innovative machine
turns seawater into bananas they're okay
that's sort of the risky take when you
make something new when you innovate
when you're an innovator who innovates
it's frankly a miracle that you can turn
seaw waterer into Fruit it would be
another separate miracle if the
resultant fruit tasted good all right so
that's Innovative let's try the verb
form innovate here at the frozen flavor
lab we're always innovating new kinds of
ice cream treats you know like frozen
chocolate dipped bananas that taste like
the brackish Waters of the Chesapeake
Bay listen they can't all be winners all
right you can learn anything Dave it out